so
two stories break over the weekend
seemingly unrelated but kind of related
okay one
is this amazing story about how china
had developed this massive missile
technology that basically took the
united states by surprise a lot of
people are calling it a second sputnik
moment sputnik of course is the moment
when the soviet union was the first to
launch a spacecraft that actually
orbited the earth and the rest of the
and the rest of the world's like whoa
where did the ussr come from here we
thought that they were way behind
technologically speaking this of course
launches the space race and leads to
president kennedy suggesting that
eventually we're going to go to the moon
right all of this was about the soviet
union surprising everyone with the
technological prowess of sending a
spacecraft into earth orbit okay well
now the chinese have basically done the
same thing and this is going to lead you
would imagine to a bit of a new arms
race here according to the uk daily mail
beijing has mocked america by saying
their secret test of a 21 000 mile per
hour nuclear-capable missile which
orbited the globe before returning to
earth to strike its target is a new blow
to the us mentality of strategic
superiority over china the job follows a
report from the financial times which
cited five unnamed intelligence sources
saying that the chinese military
launched the long march rocket in august
carrying a hypersonic glide vehicle into
low orbit
it circled the globe before descending
toward its target which it missed by
about two dozen miles in a technological
development that would overcome u.s
anti-ballistic missile systems so right
now the united states has anti-ballistic
missile systems that are largely based
in alaska because the idea is that if
the russia that if the chinese were to
fire a missile capable of striking the
united states you would have to travel
over the north part of the globe and
then we would see it and then we would
be able to use our anti-missile
technology and shoot it down from alaska
but the new technology allows the
chinese to strike the united states from
the south by sending a missile into low
orbit the incident caught the us
intelligence community by surprise it
shows china has made astonishing
progress on the development of its
hypersonic weapons according to sources
one person familiar with the test said
we have no idea how they did this to rub
salt into their wounds an op-ed in the
chinese state media global times
beijing's mouthpiece said the test means
that there's a new key member in china's
nuclear deterrence system adding this is
a new blow to the uss mentality of
strategic superiority over china so this
is explicitly an attempt to defeat the
united states missile defense system
again those hypersonic missiles can
reach speeds up to 21 000 miles per hour
they can strike anywhere on earth from
space within minutes and the goal here
is to avoid the normal trajectories
for the ballistic missiles and thus
evade u.s missile defense
so all of this is to say that china is
obviously upping the ante here china has
been becoming more and more belligerent
on the world stage they're taking
advantage of american weakness and
meanwhile what's happening here in the
united states what's happening here in
the united states is that many americans
and i would say a large percentage of
people in the democratic party are
simply embarrassed by the idea of a
muscular america period
and this has now become a cultural thing
because not only are there a lot of
americans who are embarrassed by the
idea of a muscular america at home right
we should all be embarrassed of being
americans america was founded in 1619.
america really has nothing to show the
rest of the world also at the same time
the united states should be catering to
for example the chinese market you can
see both of those moves happening in
this what would be a kind of small
cultural story normally except it really
isn't when you're talking about iconic
american art and the transformation of
that american art into a sort of
anti-american art that
there's a there's a reason for that and
it's a big problem
so the story that emerged over the
weekend is that superman is officially
moving on from the american way so the
slogan for superman so we've had a lot
about superman in the past several weeks
turns out that the new superman who is
superman's son is is bisexual which is
all very exciting and we have to have uh
superman of of every sexual orientation
before america truly has reached it's
apex as i've suggested until superman is
actually a transgender little person i i
think this is all pink washing but
superman himself right the classic
original character is going to be
getting rid of the slogan that was used
for many years for superman truth
justice in the american way now superman
as a character had been moving in this
direction for quite a while
so you'll recall then superman returns
there was a line where it was used as a
throwaway it was truth justice and all
the rest of that stuff right it's very
cynical movie and the idea was that that
there's nothing special about the
american way and truth be told if you go
back internationally to the superman
character
superman had used a variety of different
slogans over the years but the one that
everybody identified with superman was
truth justice in the american way
because that was coined during the 50s
and then it was used again in the in the
christopher reeves movie of the same
title superman in which he says truth
justice and the american way and well
now they're getting rid of it officially
jim lee the chief creative officer and
publisher of dc announced on saturday
during the virtual fan event dc fandom
that the man of steel's motto will be
evolving from the well-known mantra that
he fights for truth justice in the
american way superman's new mission
statement is truth justice and a better
tomorrow which of course suggests that
the american way is not all that great
we need quote unquote a better tomorrow
which sounds frankly like every other
revolutionary movement that has ever
taken place on planet earth truth
justice and a better tomorrow and it'd
be indistinguishable from
a chinese superman what exactly would a
chinese superman say presumably truth
justice and a better tomorrow in a press
statement the company said the decision
is meant to quote better reflect the
storylines we are telling across dc and
to honor superman's incredible legacy of
over 80 years of building a better world
so as i say the the fact is that truth
justice and the american way didn't
start with the first superman books it
was starting to it was used during the
adventures of superman tv series in the
1950s but there's no question that it
was the slogan that was most associated
with superman over the life of the
character
and now of course yeah the new superman
is not just bisexual he also marches in
favor of climate change regulation and
all the rest okay so why is this
important what's the juxtaposition to
china firing hypersonic missiles the
idea is that there is nature abhors a
vacuum and so does international
politics
when great empires like the united
states in the united states is a great
world empire it may not be a territorial
holding world empire in the same way as
the british empire but it is the global
hegemon when a global hegemon decides
that it is no longer interested in
global leadership when it starts naval
gazing and seeing that it is actually
the problem and that we have to change
our own ways that we you know we need to
bring everybody home we need to we need
to forget about our role in the world we
need to forget about our own ideals and
and how they stack up against other
ideals
because after all the united states has
its own problems when hegemon start to
do this other countries take advantage
of this
other countries are going to step into
the breach a hesitant
united states a united states that
believes that it is not inherently good
that there's no such thing as quote
unquote the american way when your
entire culture has decided that the
american way is really more akin to
racism bigotry homophobia inequality
and when you stack up the united states
not against the other countries of the
world in terms of what the united states
does and has done but in terms of some
sort of utopian ideal
you're always going to fall short but
i'll tell you what china is not having
any of those same sorts of issues right
china right now is doing two things
right they are muscular on foreign
policy and they are hyper-jingoistic at
home
so china infamously last week decided
they were going to take down the last
monument to the victims of tiananmen
square in hong kong and the rest of the
world kind of shrugged
and the rest of the world kind of
shrugged because china is doing what
countries have historically done when
they want to prove themselves muscular
on the world stage they're saying to
their own citizens that our way of life
is better and we are stronger and
meanwhile the entire west is in the
middle of
the throes of of chaos and confusion
ideologically and philosophically this
this sort of internally driven
is what's wrong with us why are we so
bad we're the problem
and the only way to correct that problem
is of course to bring home all of our
resources and then spend it on ourselves
until we die because the the best way of
fixing the problems internal to the
united states is basically to get fat
and lazy and climb into that warm
bathtub and cut open your veins like
pantangially and godfather ii
like the roman emperors of old
declining dying empires act like the
united states is acting right now
empires that are on their eyes act like
china another part of this that's so
astonishing in terms of the attitude is
that china is uniquely vulnerable right
now
so combined with china's new jingoism is
an economic junglism that's really bad
for their economy because here's the
thing now karl marx talked about the
inherent contradictions of capitalism
and how this was inevitably going to
bring about the downfall of capitalism
okay the reality is that capitalism is
extraordinarily robust and capitalism
can't be brought down by capitalism
capitalism can only be brought down by
people who wish to overthrow capitalism
that's not true with regard to communism
which relies on suppression communism
relies
on destroying people who stand in its
way and the inherent contradictions of
communism are
replete in china
right now china is experiencing some
pretty significant economic issues now
be an excellent time to take advantage
of chinese economic weakness because of
course if china is making the case for
quote-unquote the chinese way they also
have to be making the case for the
chinese communist system which is
actually a particularly unsuccessful
system
in terms of economics the only part of
the chinese system that works at all
is the part of the chinese system that
is capitalism and free trade dependent
the part of the system that is rooted in
redistribution and government subsidies
is wildly unsuccessful on a dollar to
dollar level like they'll develop a
piece of technology once in a while but
on a competing and free market stage
china can't compete which is and
meanwhile you have the leadership in
china that's turning inward xi jinping
is basically saying china ought to rule
the world and our economic system has to
get more communists not less communist
those two things are in extraordinary
contradiction
because the more china becomes more
communistic at home the weaker they are
according to the wall street journal
with its pandemic recovery in the rear
view mirror china now faces a prolonged
period of slower growth with increasing
policy uncertainties as beijing attempts
to carry out ambitious long-term reforms
china's economy recorded a steeper than
expected economic slowdown in the third
quarter of the year expanding 4.9 from a
year earlier the disappointing growth
rate reflected a host of headwinds
tighter rules on the property market
that have chilled activity in the
private sector widespread power
shortages continued concerns about kova
19.
while economists had predicted momentum
to slow from the first and second
quarters of the year as the statistical
base effect from last year faded
the chinese economy now faces a more
daunting set of challenges than it did
before seen earlier in the year
after china emerged from a coronavirus
react to 2020 as the only major world
economy to report gross domestic product
growth it set a targeted march for
expansion of six percent or more for the
year
at the same time beijing made it clear
it wanted to use the extra breathing
room to take on long festering issues in
the economy including reigning in
household and corporate debt
particularly in the country's frothy
housing market as well as pursuing
ambitious climate goals and more tightly
regulating technology sector practices
that have been seen as widening
inequality so china decided to double
down
on the communism and maoism of its
economic program as opposed to doing
what a lot of people thought they would
do which is sort of a continuing embrace
of the gradual reopening here of the
chinese economy and so china is actually
very vulnerable right now or they would
be vulnerable to a civilization that
actually cared about its future and had
the strength of its convictions but we
are not that civilization
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content